diese verfallene gebäude komplex auf
einer halbinsel gehörte einst einem
skrupellosen drogenboss
unglaublich teuer gewesen sein warum
also wurde er verlassen was ist passiert
und wieso ist er so stark beschädigt
seltsam anmutende bauten ohne
erkennbaren zweck
sie stehen einsam und verlassen auf
einem stück marschland wie aus einer
anderen welt
ruinen inmitten einer kargen landschaft
mit einer toxischen vergangenheit
es sieht aus wie bei mad max sie haben
nur verseuchte erde und zerstörung
hinterlassen
und hätten mit einem dunklen geheimnis
unter diesen hübschen verfallenen
häuschen liegt etwas sehr düsteres
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten haben
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
wer hat sie errichtet und wie
und warum wurden sie verlassen
neben einem türkisfarbenen see lago atp
in kolumbien steht eine ruine die hier
nicht so recht hin passen will
am ufer dieses riesigen sees stehen
verfallene gebäude schwer zu sagen wozu
sie einstimmten
dorthin sie sind verlassen und schwer
beschädigt aber man kann noch erkennen
dass sie einmal sehr luxuriös waren
der ein oder andere besucher spürt hier
noch die geister der vergangenheit
diese ansammlung von gebäuden in
unterschiedlich gutem zustand erstreckt
sich über eine fläche von acht hektar
[Musik]
es ist eine eigenartige mischung
es gibt türme die wachtürme sein könnten
oder nur einem dekorativen zweck
erfüllten der komplex wird wie eine
kreuzung zwischen der playboy mansion
und einer militär festung
in pflanzen überwuchern mittlerweile
viele der gebäude sie wachsen durch die
dächer und an den fassaden
wenn man genau hinsieht entdeckt man
interessante details die wände sind sehr
dick und an manchen stellen hohe es gibt
hinweise auf eine gewaltige explosion
dahinter steckt eine spannende
geschichte
wer hat hier gelebt was hat die gebäude
zerstört und was hat den ort so
gefährlich gemacht
1983 beginnen hunderte arbeiter mit dem
bau dieser außergewöhnlichen anlage es
werden keine kosten gescheut
es gab einen pool tennisplätze und ein
fußballplatz das ist per se nicht
ungewöhnlich aber auf dem fußballplatz
konnten auch hubschrauber landen und es
gab einen anlegeplatz für
wasserflugzeuge dieser art war also
alles andere als gewöhnlich
williams wohnt in der nähe und arbeitete
hier früher als wachmann
der bau des anwesens hat über sieben
jahre gedauert
während dieser zeit verändert sich auch
die gegend sehr stark doch nicht gerade
zum positiven
das nur 40 kilometer entfernte medien
ist in den 1980 ern eine der städte mit
den meisten tötungsdelikten weltweit
dort regiert das berüchtigte medien
kartell das zu seinen hochzeiten bis zu
60 millionen dollar am tag durch den
verkauf von drogen einnimmt
einer seiner gründer ist pablo escobar
er wird 1949 in rio negro geboren und
gilt bis heute als der reichste
kriminelle in der geschichte
anfang der 90er verfügt er über ein
vermögen von geschätzten 30 milliarden
dollar damit ist er einer der
wohlhabendsten menschen der welt
er beginnt seine kriminelle laufbahn mit
dem verkauf geschmuggelter zigaretten
und gefälschter lotterie scheine am ende
ist er der boss eines umfangreichen
drogen imperiums und für entführungen
schmuggel und morde verantwortlich
pablo escobar konnte nie richtig
entspannen er war immer von bodyguards
umgeben er hat der bewaffnete wachen und
mauern die so dick waren wie die einer
festung
escobar war immer auf der hut
um für seine familie einen sicheren
rückzugsort zu schaffen lässt escobar
die agenda la manuela baum sie ist nach
seiner tochter benannt und seine lieben
sollen es sich dort so richtig gut gehen
lassen
[Musik]
seine familie war hin und wieder dort
seine mutter seine frau und seine kinder
es war zum leben gedacht kein versteck
die agenda ist teil einer reihe von
luxuriösen anwesen die escobar gehören
auf einem nicht weit entfernten gibt es
eine stierkampf-arena und einen zoo
manuela ist zwar weniger extravagant
aber sie verfügt über geheimfächer
verstecke und ein labyrinth aus fluren
außerdem hat es coca hier einen
hubschrauber und ein schnellboot mit
denen er sofort die flucht ergreifen
kann
[Musik]
denn sicherheit ist ihm wichtiger als
luxus
diesen familiensitz ließ escobar von 120
sicherheitsleuten bewacht
es war eine kleine armee
es war irgendwie paradox
escobar wollte einen schönen ort für
seine familie mit einem pool für die
kinder gleichzeitig schließt er dort
aber drogen und bargeld durch das
anwesen war umringt von bewaffneten
wachen und wasserflugzeugen und
schnellboote kamen und gingen ich denke
kaum dass man dort entspannen konnte
der drogenbaron selbst lässt sich hier
nur selten blicken
pablo bei höchstens zwei oder drei mal
dort und dann auch nur ein paar stunden
er hat nicht mal übernachtet
als reichster mann der welt muss man
ständig wachsam sein
in den frühen 90ern entbrennt ein
erbitterter krieg zwischen escobar und
der kolumbianischen regierung
nach einem kurzen gefängnisaufenthalt
gelingt ihm 1992 die flucht den rest
seines lebens muss er sich verstecken
da escobars medien kartell den us
amerikanischen markt mit fast 80 prozent
des verfügbaren kokains versorgt sind
ihm nicht nur die kolumbianische polizei
und die us-regierung auf den fersen
sondern auch konkurrierende
drogenkartelle
nach und nach werden auch die
sicherheitsleute der us-sender manuela
in die kämpfe verwickelt
1993 schafften des escobars rivalen auf
das anwesen
gegen mitternacht kamen sechs voll
besetzte pickups und ein minibus
die männer brachten zwei bomben eine an
jeder seite
sie haben eine riesige menge sprengstoff
in einem badezimmer deponiert und
hochgehen lassen
die lag die größte bombe
es gab eine riesige explosion alles
wackelte
ist das badezimmer in dem die bombe
hochging
die wände wurden komplett zerstört
so stark war die detonation
sehen sie hier kein stein mehr auf dem
anderen
die vereinigung die hinter dem anschlag
steckt ist los babys eine bürgerwehr die
von opfern escobars gegründet wurde
in unterlagen der ca
die 2008 veröffentlicht werden finden
sich hinweise darauf dass der
kolumbianische geheimdienst mit los
babys in kontakt steht
wahrscheinlich wurden sie von seinen
konkurrenten von kali karte finanziert
genau werden wir das nie wissen aber
dieser bombenanschlag war der anfang vom
ende für escobar
wenn du jeden wird zum schlachtfeld in
escobars krieg um die vorherrschaft
gegen verfeindete kartelle die
regierungen von kolumbien und den usa
der drogen was besetzt sogar kopfgelder
auf kolumbianische polizisten aus
der anschlag auf seine agenda bietet der
polizei eine einzigartige gelegenheit
herrlich polizei einheiten stürmten das
gelände und beschlagnahmten drogen und
geld auf die sie nun dank der explosion
zugriff hatten
obwohl es keine toten gibt hat der
vorfall erhebliche auswirkungen für
william und andere die auf der agenda
arbeiten
nach dem anschlag wurde das leben für
viele sehr schwierig
zwei bis dreihundert anwohner die auf
dem anwesen gearbeitet hatten verloren
ihren job
das war für mich das schlimmste
[Musik]
für den berüchtigten könig des kokains
wird es langsam eng
er schmierte einen großteil der
kolumbianischen regierung und der
strafverfolgungsbehörden trotzdem hatten
sie ihn und sein ende rückte immer näher
die fahndung nach escobar leitet coronel
roal martinez von der nationalpolizei
kolumbiens er verfolgt escobar bereits
seit jahren hat mehrere
bestechungsversuche abgelehnt und sein
leben aufs spiel gesetzt
nun gelingt es ihm endlich mittels funk
teilung escobars aufenthaltsort zu
ermitteln
während eines heftigen feuergefecht
werden der drogenbaron und sein
leibwächter auf ihrer flucht über die
hausdächer niedergeschossen
er stirbt als einer der meistgesuchten
kriminellen der geschichte der schaden
den er angerichtet hat ist nicht
wiedergutzumachen
wie in jedem krieg starben auch hier
viele unschuldige menschen die nichts
mit all dem zu tun hatten medien in
wuppertal und in vielen anderen städten
kolumbiens
[Musik]
was wird aus pablo escobars anwesen
manche werden zur skurilen freizeitparks
umgebaut und andere dem erdboden
gleichgemacht
doch dieser wohnkomplex fristet sein
dasein in einem seltsamen schwebezustand
[Musik]
ich führe gerade einen rechtsstreit
gegen die regierung um als besitzer des
anwesens anerkannt zu werden
ich habe mich darum gekümmert es instand
gehalten und dafür gesorgt dass es
niemand betritt
[Musik]
zu entscheiden was aus einem grundstück
wird das mit drogen geld finanziert
wurde und was mit dem gewinn durch
seinen verkauf geschehen soll ist eine
heikle angelegenheit
bis heute spaltet pablo escobar
kolumbien in zwei lager die einen sehen
ihn immer noch als nationalhelden doch
für diejenigen die opfer seiner gewalt
wurden steht er stellvertretend für die
probleme des landes
[Musik]
in den wäldern von wünsdorf vor den
toren von berlin stehen häuser die erst
einmal typisch für diese gegend
erscheinen
sie sehen aus wie kleine ferienhäuschen
an denen sich jemand so richtig
ausgetobt hat
wenn man genauer hinschaut kommen
zweifel auf ob es wirklich normale
wohnhäuser sind der beton ist sehr dick
und an manchen stellen wurde er
verstärkt
unter diesen hübschen verfallenen
häuschen geht etwa sehr düsteres
[Musik]
mitten in der natur findet man ein
harmlos anmutende gebäude
sich dazu eintritt zu verschaffen ist
jedoch alles andere als einfach so man
hat das gefühl ein geheimnis gewölbe zu
betreten
sie versuchten das was sie taten so gut
es ging vor den augen der öffentlichkeit
zu verbergen
[Musik]
an diesem ort waren einige der
mächtigsten armeen der welt stationiert
darüber kann der leiter der
sehenswürdigkeit werner borchert
berichten
in ganz deutschland gibt es keinen
anderen ort an dem der deutsche kaiser
hitler und die sowjets ihre
militärischen spuren hinterließen
ende der 30er jahre warum die nazis auf
dem gelände eine geheime
kommandozentrale früher war hier ein
truppenübungsplatz der kaiserlichen
armee
es war eines der wichtigsten
kommunikationszentren der wehrmacht
während des zweiten weltkriegs der bau
wurde gerade rechtzeitig zu hitlers
überfall auf polen fertig
dies ist maybach einst das hauptquartier
des oberkommandos des deutschen heeres
sein herz ist der zeppelin bunker
wie community
kommunikationseinrichtungen sowie die
kommando und kontroll einrichtungen in
diesem bunker waren die zentren der
deutschen kriegsführung
ein bisschen so wie das pentagon in
washington
in der englischsprachigen welt sind wir
fasziniert davon auf welche weise der
enigma code geknackt wurde
der zeppelin bunker ist der ort von dem
die nachrichten kamen die später vom
britischen geheimdienst in bletchley
park abgehört und entschlüsselt wurden
der standort muss gut getarnt werden
die gebäude sollten wohnhäuser
begleichen
sie bekamen dachziegel und verputzte
wände hatten fenster attrappen und die
stahltüren wurden mit holz verkleidet
damit sie wie gewöhnliche haustüren
auswahl
außerdem sind sie niedrig gebaut und
über eine große fläche des dichten
waldes verteilt
sie waren nicht angeordnet wie man es
erwarten würde aus der luft deutete
nichts auf einen militärkomplex hin
im verlauf des krieges versuchen die
alliierten die bunkeranlage immer wieder
zu bombardieren
diesen bunker komplex zu bombardieren er
forderte mehr geschick als bomben auf
eine stadt abzuwerfen
von denen erhielt nun ein klares radar
signal und konnte sich an prägnanten
punkten mit zb einem fluss orientieren
im hinterland gab es nur wenige
referenzpunkte
das ziel zu finden ist für die
alliierten bomber eine erinnerung
herausforderung
dass die anlage wie eine normale
wohngegend der zivilbevölkerung wird und
sich ein großteil unter der erde
befindet macht die aufgabe nicht gerade
leichter
[Musik]
ein unterirdisches tunnelsystem
verbindet die zwölf bunker von denen
gänge zum zeppelin bunker führen der
sich auf zwei etagen und einer fläche
von über 4500 quadratmetern erstreckt
seine wände sind drei meter dick und von
einer zusätzlichen betonhülle
umschlossen
die arbeiter dürfen immer nur für kurze
zeit an dem bau mitwirken damit sie
nicht so viel über sein inneres in
erfahrung bringen
es ist reines glück dass die alliierten
am ende erfolgreich sind
im nationalarchiv der vereinigten
staaten befinden sich unterlagen von
verhören die im februar
1944 mit mitarbeitern der nachrichten
einheit geführt wurden
diesen berichteten sie über einen bunker
auf dem land nach belieben
[Musik]
die nachrichtendienste der alliierten
sind nun noch mehr von der wichtigkeit
der bunkeranlage überzeugt doch das
größte problem ist immer noch sie zu
finden
um den standort der bunker ausfindig zu
machen
doch dann griffen sie an mit aller macht
am 15 märz 1945 fliegen
675 us bomber einen angriff um die
bunker zu zerstören
[Musik]
die 120 menschen die hier starben waren
alle zivilisten
denn sie waren nicht durch die bunker
geschützt
trotz der vielen bomben wird der
militärkomplex kaum beschädigt doch im
april 1945 drückt die sowjetische armee
immer näher zur anlage vor
der vorstoß der roten armee erfolgte so
schnell dass die deutschen kalt erwischt
worden
adolf hitler ist schockiert als er hört
dass die sowjetischen panzer keine
stunde mehr von maybach 1 entfernt sind
das hauptquartier des oberkommandos des
deutschen heeres steht kurz vor seiner
einnahme
die sowjets mussten anhalten um
aufzutanken in der zeit sind alle aus
dem hauptquartier geflogen
der generalstabschef des heeres ans
krebs bittet hitler um erlaubnis maybach
1 verlassen und wichtige geräte und
dokumente vernichten zu dürfen hitler
stimmt widerwillig zu doch zu spät es
ist keine zeit mehr irgendetwas zu
zerstören sie müssen alles zurücklassen
als die mitarbeiter in panik aus dem
gebäude fliehen werden sie versehentlich
von ihrem eigenen flugzeugen angegriffen
am nachmittag des 20 april 1945 rollen
die panzer der dritten sowjetischen
garde panzerarmee auf das verlassene
gelände
die soldaten sind überrascht was sie
dort vorfinden
was sie fanden
angeblich nur vier männer drei von ihnen
haben sich sofort ergeben der vierte war
zu betrunken um mitzubekommen was vor
sich ging
ein großteil der ausrüstung wird
abgebaut und in die sowjetunion gebracht
wo stalin den bau einer ähnlichen anlage
befiehlt mit unterzeichnung des
potsdamer abkommens vom august 1945 hat
sich die sowjetunion eigentlich
verpflichtet militärische einrichtungen
zu zerstören aber das geschah in diesem
falle nur recht halbherzig
überdies haben sie einiges in die luft
gesprengt aber die tunnel und bürger
haben sie größtenteils stehen lassen
immer dort unten ist sieht man dass die
sowjets so schlau waren das meiste
intakt zu lassen
diese jetzt setzen den zeppelin bunker
und das tunnelsystem wieder entstand um
dort die kommandozentrale ihrer eigenen
armee in deutschland einzurichten
sie sichern den bunker sogar gegen
atomwaffen
diese bunker sollten die
kommandozentrale bei der zerschlagung
der nato durch die sowjetunion sein
von hieraus sollten ihre kommandeure im
falle eines dritten weltkriegs europa
zerstören
zum glück kommt es nicht dazu
die letzten sowjetischen soldaten
verlassen erst 1994 das gelände
[Musik]
heute geben die ruinen einen
faszinierenden einblick in die
kriegsführung der vergangenen jahrzehnte
[Musik]
nie wieder krieg das ist unser appell
deswegen zeigen wir die militärische
vergangenheit hier in münster auf nie
wieder krieg
im süden portugals nur einige kilometer
vor der grenze zu spanien sieht es aus
wie auf einem anderen planeten
[Musik]
es wirkt wie eine narbe in der
landschaft überall ist es grün aber in
der mitte tut sich eine wüstenartigen
schneise auf
die überall sieht man spannende farben
schwarze hügel gelbe streifen rötliches
wasser
oberflächlich betrachtet recht schön
aber diese farben haben in diesem
landstrich eigentlich nichts verloren
in dieser unwirtlichen landschaft findet
man leere gebäude aufgegebene
schienensysteme und seltsame türme die
dabei sind zu verfallen
aber diese ruinen sind nicht das
verstörendste
das wasser ist dunkel und hinterlässt am
ufer einen roten sei
ein krasser anblick und irgendwie
verrückt
die gesamte gegend und die gebäude sind
kaputt und verfallen als hätte sie
jemand vergiftet ja alles wirkt
irgendwie vergiftet
wie kam es dazu und warum sieht es hier
heute noch so aus
die karge landschaft und die defekten
bauten sind nicht die einzigen düsteren
hinterlassenschaften an diesem ort in
der nähe liegt ein kleiner friedhof der
einen hinweis darauf gibt was hier
vorgefallen ist
wir sind mitten in portugal und die
grabsteine auf dem friedhof tragen nur
englische namen
portugal und spanien sind reich an
bodenschätzen
davon wollten die briten einen teil
abhaben
im neunzehnten jahrhundert pachtet eine
englische firma das land und beginnt
tagebau zu betragen
doch sie waren nicht die ersten weist
der örtliche tourismusbeauftragte so
rola
dieser ort ist sehr alt wir waren schon
die phönizier und die römer
als die engländer im 19 jahrhundert
kamen entstand hier die größte
industriell betriebene mine europas
die miene von domingos wird um 1850
eröffnet und erstreckt sich
kilometerweit über die landschaft des
alentejo
diese mine war ein riesiges
industrielles unterfangen um es zu
betreiben bedurfte es einer aufwändigen
infrastrukturen
es war der erste ort in portugal an dem
es eine eisenbahnstrecke und
elektrizität gab
im ganzen tal gab es unterschiedliche
verarbeitung station auf gleisen wurde
das material aus der mine gebracht und
dann weiter bis zu einem hafen an der
küste transportiert
der betrieb der mine verhilft der region
zu einem wirtschaftlichen aufschwung und
schafft vieler arbeitsplätze
doch wie man heute sieht hat das nicht
nur vorteile für
portugal war es der eintritt in die
moderne doch der preis dafür war hoch
und die folgen waren schrecklich
wo ein hoher profit winkt leidet auf die
umwelt das ist auch jeder fall wie man
an seltsam gefärbten wasser unschwer
erkennen kann
ein see oder fluss auf dem land lebt
häufig zu einem erfrischenden bad ein
aber bei dieser schwarz roten brühe weiß
man sofort dass hier etwas nicht stimmen
[Musik]
da drüben sieht man schwarzes wasser
und grund hier bei ihm ihr gutes es ist
wie das blut der erde
vor ein paar jahren hat sich der dunkle
sie sogar plötzlich entzündet
das rote und schwarze wasser stand in
flammen sie breiteten sich schnell aus
wir wissen nicht was das feuer ausgelöst
hat vielleicht war es eigentlich
chemischen reaktion wir können es nicht
sagen
die ursache des feuers bleibt weiter
unklar doch an der färbung des wassers
kann man erkennen was in der mine
abgebaut wurde und warum es hier heute
so aussieht
roth denke ich sofort an eisen das
wasser ist stark mit eisenoxid verseucht
aber ich weiß dass hier kein eisen
gefördert wurde
die engländer suchten nach
unterschiedlichen wertvollen
bodenschätzen
gold silber kupfer geologisch gesehen
findet man sie oft am selben ort sie
haben sich auf kupfer konzentriert
das neunzehnte jahrhundert bringt in
europa große veränderungen und portugal
läuft gefahr abgehängt zu werden
die mine soll domingo soll dem land
helfen teil der industriellen revolution
zu werden
[Musik]
kupfer ist ein begehrtes metall es hat
viele interessante eigenschaften ist ein
guter wärme und strom leiter des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts wurde es für
elektrische leitungen verwendet in den
anfängen der elektrizität wurde viel
davon gebraucht
doch um profitabel zu bleiben muss die
mine immer wieder den bedarf angepasst
werden
später konzentrierten sie sich auf
schwefel der auch dort vorkam im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert entdeckte man
dass schwefelsäure für alles mögliche
verwendet werden kann wie zum beispiel
für die herstellung von dünger deswegen
wurde die mine auf schwefel umgestellt
die eingestürzten türme und ruinen
erzählen ihre eigene geschichte
doch die zerstörung der landschaft ist
folge der förderung der metalle und
ihrer bearbeitung durch chemikalien
die hälfte presse man muss den stein
arbeiten und dafür braucht man jede
menge wasser man muss ihn erhitzen und
die mineralien schmelzen um das kupfer
aus der verbindung zu lösen in der er
sich befindet
das verunreinigte wasser aus der
verarbeitung muss irgendwie entsorgt
werden und so wird es einfach auf das
umliegende land abgelassen
mit dem wasser pumpen sie auch alle
möglichen giftstoffe in den fluss kaum
auszumalen was mit den menschen die an
seinem ufer lebten
die auswirkungen des vergifteten wassers
sind für die natur dramatisch
hier war überall verseuchtes wasser um
es abzufangen bauten sie einen staudamm
sehen sie die unterschiede in der
landschaft
sind für die region alentejo typische
oliven und kock bäume und hier
sieht es aus wie auf dem mond oder dem
mars
wenn man schwefel mit wasser mischt
bekommt man schwefelsäure sie ist
unglaublich giftig diese landschaft ist
bis tief in die erde mit der säure
versetzt
die farben die steine hier ist kein
leben möglich als wäre es radioaktiv
verseucht
nicht nur die erde wird verseucht
giftige gase gelangen in die luft und
werden von den arbeitern in der mine
eingeatmet
menschen irgendwann spürten die arbeiter
die folgen
was sie aus der erde holt verletzte ihre
ausrüstung es verletze ihre kleidung und
schließlich sogar ihre haut
die gesundheit der arbeiter wird über
die jahre erheblich geschädigt doch das
nimmt die firma billigend in kauf bis
die mine 1966 geschlossen wird
[Musik]
die menschen verloren ihre arbeit die
gesamte region liegt darunter
die mine und die bevölkerung werden
einfach aufgegeben
[Musik]
heute soll das land durch umfangreiche
sanierungsarbeiten zurückgewonnen werden
doch das ist ein langwieriges und
gefährliches unterfangen
wenn man elemente mit der hölle
verbindet dann sind es schwefel und
feuer ein ort der mit schwefel verseucht
ist ist wirklich ziemlich nah an der
hölle
[Musik]
an der küste von kent in südengland
stehen mitten im marschland seltsame
bauwerke
riesige gebilde ragen aus dem boden sie
sehen wie satelliten schüsseln aus beton
aus
sie haben etwas fremdartiges an sich sie
wirken wie aus der zeit gefallen
das erste mal habe ich sie als teenager
gesehen futuristische objekte im
nirgendwo
[Musik]
zwei untertassen ähnliche bauten und
eine riesige gebogene mauer
99 prozent der menschen tatsächlich auch
die anwohner und wissen nicht worum es
sich dabei handelt
trotz ihrer einfachen anmutung waren sie
einmal von größter bedeutung
sie sind aus beton doch anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts waren sie auf
dem neuesten stand der technik
der erste weltkrieg rief sie auf dem
plan
in diesem krieg ist der
artillerie-beschuss aus großer distanz
ein wichtiger bestandteil der
kriegsführung
mit hilfe von mikrofonen wird versucht
die stellung des feindes ausfindig zu
machen
eine ähnliche technologie wird heute von
der polizei in den usa verwendet um
schießereien zuordnung
im weiteren verlauf des ersten
weltkriegs werden neue schall
messverfahren entwickelt um in dieser
neuen art der kriegsführung bestehen zu
können diese bauten entstanden nach dem
ersten weltkrieg und sie zeigen in
richtung mehr es kann also nicht um
artilleriebeschuss gegangen sein
[Musik]
der standort der konstruktionen direkt
an der küste mit blick auf den
ärmelkanal gibt einen hinweis auf ihren
verwendungszweck
[Musik]
sie wurden gebaut um die geräusche von
feindlichen flugzeugen aufzufangen
selbst wenn es nur ein paar minuten bis
zum sichtkontakt waren blieb genug zeit
um die eigenen flugzeuge zu starten das
land zu verteidigen und die
zivilbevölkerung in bunkern in
sicherheit zu bringen
[Musik]
dies sind die hohlspiegel mikrofone vom
tisch
sie stehen auf einer landzunge bei
dungeon es nur 40 kilometer von der
französischen küste und dem europäischen
festland entfernt
da die umgebung verhältnismäßig ruhig
ist konnten sie sich ganz auf die
geräusche über den mehr konzentrieren
es ist ganz einfach ihre funktionsweise
zu erklären wenn man etwas besser hören
will dann macht man so
das machen auch die mikrofone nur in
viel größeren maßstab sie fangen den
schall ein und verstärken
[Musik]
entworfen werden sie von dem physiker
persie rafael
das erste der hohlspiegel mikrofone wird
1928 gebaut bereits kurz darauf folgt
das zweite
mit fast neun metern war es größer als
das erste und wurde in einem anderen
winkel aufgestellt
der parabolspiegel hier geht tiefer je
stärker sie gewölbt sind desto stärker
ist das signal
was die reichweite betrifft ist das kein
vorteil
doch die flugbahn der flugzeuge kann
genauer bestimmt werden in den späten
1930 er jahren erfolgt der nächste
schritt
der star der show war der lange spiegel
er ist 60 meter lang und acht meter hoch
es ist das größte bauwerk dieser art das
ist je gab
es war nicht nur eine große betonmauer
sondern ein hochentwickeltes
wissenschaftliches gerät
die gebogene oberfläche bündelt die
schallwellen die an den wänden abprallen
und
reflektiert sie auf einen bestimmten
punkt an dem das mikrofon positioniert
ist
die messergebnisse werden mit denen
anderer wohl spiegel mikrofone
verglichen so können hohe
geschwindigkeit und flugbahn der
maschinen berechnet werden ein techniker
der bei den spiegeln stationiert ist
versucht mit hilfe eines stethoskop die
unterschiedlichen geräusche zu erkennen
die hohlspiegel mikrofone wirken sehr
einfach aber sie zu bedienen war keine
leichte aufgabe
der techniker saß ungefähr hier mit
einem rad konnte er das mikrofon hin und
her bewegen er war gegen die witterung
geschützt und bekam keine anderen
geräusche von außen mit hier konnte er
sich besser konzentrieren als draußen
die geräusche von flugzeug- oder
schiffsmotoren von anderen geräuschen zu
unterscheiden war extrem schwierig man
musste hochkonzentriert sein deswegen
waren die schichten der techniker nur 40
minuten lang
[Musik]
nachteil dieser technologie war dass
alle geräusche aufgefangen und verstärkt
wurden wenn ganz in der nähe vögel waren
übertönte gezwitscher manchmal den lärm
der flugzeuge
außerdem macht die luftfahrttechnik
rasante fortschritte
[Musik]
in den 1920 er anfang der 1930 er jahre
wurden die flugzeuge immer schneller
dank weniger widerstand und
leistungsstärkerer triebwerke hatte sich
ihre geschwindigkeit fast verdoppelt
die linie brachten das auf knapp 100 km
in der stunde
extrem auf doch schon anfang der
dreißiger jahre erreichten flugzeuge
über 300 km h kampflugzeuge so war an
die 500 wenn man sie in 20 kilometern
entfernung entdeckt waren sie nur wenige
minuten weit weg
mit der massiven aufrüstung hat sie
deutschlands steigt ab mitte der 1930 er
jahre die militärische bedrohung adolf
hitler investiert besonders in den
aufbau der luftwaffe
[Musik]
unter der federführung der nazis wurde
die luftfahrttechnik enorm
weiterentwickelt die geschwindigkeit der
flugzeuge nahm rasant zu sie rechtzeitig
zu orten wurde also immer schwieriger
die vorwarnzeit durch schall
messverfahren wurde immer kürzer doch
die entwicklung des radars machte gute
fortschritte
erst löste die alten ordnungsverfahren
gerade rechtzeitig ab als die flugzeuge
für sie zu schnell wurden die
systeme entlang der englischen küste
wurden gegen neue ausgetauscht
nach der entwicklung und installation
der hohlspiegel mikrofone wurde 1935 der
radar erfunden diese futuristische
technologie machte die parabolspiegel
überflüssig sie sehen aus wie uralte
denkmäler und irgendwie sind sie es auch
denkmäler überholter technologie
obwohl die hohlspiegel mikrofone vom
radar abgelöst werden spielen sie bei
der luftschlacht um england eine
entscheidende rolle
der himmel über südostengland wird zum
kriegsschauplatz als die luftwaffe 1940
mit ihren angriffen beginnt
ihr oberbefehlshaber hermann göring hat
hitler versichert dass sie england in
die kapitulation zwingen würde
[Musik]
doch die kampfflugzeuge der royal air
force und die britischen truppen am
boden machen einen strich durch die
rechnung
[Musik]
es war nicht nur die technologie die bei
der luftschlacht um england entscheidend
war sondern auch die organisation
der radar der zwar eine höhere
genauigkeit und eine größere reichweite
doch das kommunikationssystem dass die
hauptquartiere und andere stellungen
verband hat er schon vorher bestanden
deswegen funktioniert in die
luftverteidigung so gut und half 1940
großbritannien und die welt zu retten
heute ist diese gegend ein
naturschutzgebiet und die objekte geben
einen faszinierenden einblick in die
vergangenheit
die spiegel sind schwer zu erreichen und
werden der öffentlichkeit auch nur ein
oder zweimal im jahr zugänglich gemacht
aber so kann dieses stück geschichte
besser bewahrt werden das ansonsten
sicher verloren gegangen wäre so nach
einem krieg werden solche bauten oft
demontiert und weggeschafft diese wurden
als eine art andenken an die geniale
technologie erhalten die bei der
verteidigung großbritanniens half
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie könnten von krieg
und terror von erfindergeist und
menschlichen streben nach fortschritt